April April I need you in the audience
okay wait and if the questions start
getting negative I'm gonna call on you
and I need you to sell the crap out of
the park can you do that why please
April this is serious can you do that
probably good girl good girl good
probably good girl okay here we go line
up everybody you know what this is a
public forum which means that we all get
to tell you what we think well you did
already talk ma'am and I would love to
listen to someone else someone I don't
know uh that girl over there with long
brown hair and the yellow top could you
tell us how you feel about this park
go ahead hi
uh I'm a youth in the community and I
think a new park is a great idea and I
fully support it as would the rest of
the youth in the community hey guys
how's everything going April we couldn't
be happier and you are an angel for
asking yeah it's surprisingly painless
the swiping no passive aggressive
comments
no drama at all
here are all the troublemakers boss
thank you Migos I am not screwing around
okay Lauren no more discussion of
Mallorca Mallorca is off limits Brian
and Gloria stop making Horatio feel bad
that your daughter went to Yale no one
gets it
and genuine yes get it together oh sorry
April Kathy started this
she doesn't mean it don't cry Genie why
it's okay
thanks Andy
easy peasy
lemon Sneezy come on Ron I've been a
loyal foot soldier give me my shot let
me have lot 48.
is that a travel pillow around your neck
run
saying this to you when you've been down
in the pit have you been in the pit
no I haven't gotten down there yet well
I have when you fell in when I visited
the bottom of the pit on a fact-finding
mission
and when you're down there you get some
perspective about what it all means
let me tell you something Ron
what it means is
I want this subcommittee
I've been quite open about this around
the office I don't want this parks
department to build any parks because I
don't believe in government I think that
all government
is a waste of taxpayer money my dream is
to have the park system privatized and
run entirely for profit by corporations
like Chuck E cheese
they have an impeccable business model I
would rather work for Chuck E cheese
hey there you are
feeding me here well if you'd have held
him here instead of that conference room
I would have come to more meetings I got
to tell you Leslie establishing this
National Park right next to Pawnee is
quite an accomplishment
this is a fine piece of land you saved
thank you Ron
you want to run it
the superintendent of Bryce Canyon
retired and I convinced the
superintendent of this park to transfer
shuffled a few things around the point
is someone needs to take care of this
place now thought it should be you
all right
well first of all I would be working for
the federal government your job would be
to walk around the land alone you'd live
in the same town you've always lived in
you'd work outside you'd talk to Bears
next argument there must be dozens of
people gunning for this job I wouldn't
want you to ruffle any feathers am I
even qualified well a few people might
be annoyed but they'll get over it and
as far as your qualifications you're Ron
Swanson
stop being a dummy and accept
when do I start oh today I already
accepted for you I still remember how to
forge your signature let's go meet your
staff
Pawnee National Park Rangers this is Ron
Swanson your new superintendent and boss
Rangers
my name is Ronald Ulysses Swanson
your job and mine is to walk this land
and make sure no one harms it
if you show up on time speak honestly
and treat everyone with fairness we will
get along just fine
though hopefully not too fine as I'm not
looking for any new friends end of
speech
well said
thank you Leslie
you're welcome Ron
I'm going in
why don't worry I have a hard hat on I
can see that but yeah April document
this key to any fact-finding mission is
to get right into the Battle Zone you
know it's like George Bush when he flew
over New Orleans or Richard Nixon when
he went to China to see what the Chinese
were up to no oh oh oh oh oh oh
Wesley are you okay
you know that the national park system
deserves this land why are you trying to
screw me this is like Morningstar all
over again this is nothing like
Morningstar and that was two years ago
well you don't know who you're dealing
with I directly oversee 1200 people I
have a staff of creative Geniuses that
will not stop working until we win this
bid Leslie I I couldn't find that file
you wanted but I did find a file called
bird census 1980.
and it's empty get out of here Ed I
fired you right if anybody wants to hang
I will be at Subway
he's very stupid honey can you
straighten up your area a little bit
because they're going to be here soon
okay
thanks that perks lady is coming over
and we're gonna go take a look at the
pit
I think it's probably just a photo op
for her I mean I don't think anybody in
government actually cares about honey do
you mind doing it somewhere else I'm
trying to watch TV
I'm talking about the pit you fell in
this must be our hero
the man heard round the world
how you doing son are you good I'm
Leslie Knope
and the entire government to Pawnee
would like to let you know that we will
do everything we can to help you did you
pass me my itch stick of course
it takes like eight hours to cook
something in this thing I guess I could
pick up a brisket tomorrow and start it
for dinner Thursday well Thursday's no
good I have production meetings all day
and we've got dinner with Joe and Don on
Friday hey you know Sunday we go to the
farmer's market put the brisket in the
slow cooker get a movie on pay-per-view
the new Jason Bourne movie's supposed to
be pretty funny
[Music]
we are planning our whole week like old
people we used to be spontaneous and
weird we used to eat cereal out of
Frisbees because we didn't have any
bowls if you once broke a rib trying to
rustle one of those inflatable floppy
guys at a car dealership now you
sprained your shoulder trying to clean
out this stupid gutter you even have a
job we have a bank account that's it
we've held out as long as we could but
it finally happened we're boring we're
boring People Who Bore each other by
being born no we are still fun I'm gonna
prove it to you tonight at the gala
we're gonna do something spontaneous and
weird okay
stopped haunting me fine
you want the truth yes
could I have gotten my cast off two
weeks ago technically
yes but
I really really like it when you serve
me food get out get out of my house
take a walk with your overly healed legs
and let me think about this relationship
oh it's a common misconception that the
Oculus holds all of the Power it's
actually The Lamplighter and oh my God
it's happening it's totally happening
our kids are falling in love
good okay okay remember if this is ever
going to work we have to pretend to
disapprove yeah right good call
no oh
who cares
all right